[Musik]
neue chor ohne regeln für deutschland
auf den kompromiss von bund und ländern
folgten neuer streit und die frage ob
die maßnahmen reichen frieren in mathe
und deutsch alle 20 minuten stoßlüften
soll die schulen durch den corona winter
bringen
frankreich im gesundheitsnotstand
präsident makram reagiert auf die
steigenden krone zahlen mit einer
ausgangssperre
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann dabei hunderte von mir
es sollte eigentlich ein historisches
treffen werden gestern bei der
bundeskanzlerin
bund und länder wollten sich angesichts
der rasant wachsenden infektionszahlen
auf eine gemeinsame linie einigen
das ist zumindest beim sogenannten
beherbergungs verbot krachend
gescheitert und sorgt heute für
ernüchterung und kritik dennoch gab es
auch konsens welche regeln konkret
beschlossen wurden erklärt uns thomas
konsum die strengeren maßnahmen einige
gelten künftig schon bei 35
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohnern wo
so viele fälle gibt greift eine
ergänzende masken pflicht maske auf wo
menschen dicht zusammen kommen das
könnten fußgängerzonen sein und private
feiern werden begrenzt auf 25 teilnehmer
im öffentlichen raum im privaten auf 15
wo noch mehr neue infektionen auftreten
50 pro 100000 einwohner dürfen nur noch
zehn personen zusammen feiern zu hause
maximal zwei haus stände für treffen
allgemein zugelassen in der
öffentlichkeit nur bis zu zehn auf
veranstaltungen höchstens 100 personen
mehr nur mit genehmigten konzept und die
gastronomie hat eine sperrstunde 23 uhr
neue ansteckungen neue regeln und ein
appell vom bund jeder soll reisen in und
aus hotspots unterlassen
genau diese gebiete in deutschland
nehmen zu heißt die neuen regeln gelten
für immer mehr menschen
das hier sind die regionen im land mit
mehr als 35 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohner in einer woche viele andere
landkreise und städte zählen bereits
mehr als 50 zahlen die die politik
beschäftigen und für streit sorgen heute
wieder
und gestern sehr lange im kanzleramt aus
berlin berichtet andreas kühner ist
es muss ganz schön gerumpelt haben im
kanzleramt vergangenen nacht als die
ministerpräsidenten wieder rauskommen
beben manche noch ein bisschen nach da
habe ich ihn einfach sagen dass einzelne
bundesländer jetzt schon leute einfach
nach hause geschickt haben und mein
bundesland hat das nicht gemacht das
beherbergungs verbot in der jetzigen
form ist nicht verhältnismäßig es trifft
so viele menschen die nichts mit dieser
krankheit zu tun haben und deswegen wäre
es besser gewesen wenn es hier eine
verständigung gegeben hat es gab keine
verständigung sachsen und das saarland
heben ihr beherbergungs verbot heute
einseitig auf sieben andere bundesländer
versuchen ihre zu verteidigen
die kanzlerin wollte es einheitlich und
wollte es streng
das ergebnis fällt merkel für nicht
vorsichtig genug wenn sie mich fragen
was ist das was mich beunruhigt dann ist
das der exponentielle anstieg und den
müssen wir stoppen sonst wird es in kein
gutes ende führen masken pflicht
sperrstunde kontakt beschränkung einig
sind sich bund und länder die maßnahmen
dort zu verschärfen wo die neue
infektionen besonders stark steigen denn
wenn berlin jetzt hier zum beispiel
feiern einschränkt auf zehn personen
dann muss das in mecklenburg vorpommern
nicht sein wenn die zahlen viel
niedriger sind
die drastische warnung kommt auch heute
wieder aus bayern
wir müssen der wahrheit ins auge sehen
wir rücken jeden tag einem lockdown
näher
wenn wir jetzt nicht konsequent
reagieren wenn wir jetzt nicht
entschlossen angehen und uns der
situation stellen dann ist manches von
dem was wir uns gar nicht vorstellen
können was kommen könnte sehr schnell
und schneller als wir denken realität
aus dem medizinischen alltag ein
vorsichtiges lob für die berliner
beschlüsse sind also verschiedene
maßnahmen die ergriffen worden sind ich
hoffe dass das zusammenwirken dieser
verschiedenen maßnahmen ausreichen dass
wir eben die dämpfen
aus der wirtschaft dagegen heftige
kritik wir haben jetzt die situation die
gelöst werden muss und dann ein thema
tatsächlich weil man sich nicht einig
ist zu vertagen
auf den 8 11 das ist meines erachtens
nach wirklich und verantwortlich am
mittag greifen die gerichte ein und
heben das beherbergungs verbot in
niedersachsen und baden württemberg auf
natürlich ist es gegen meinen willen wir
leben in einem rechtsstaat
da die judikative das letzte wort und
nicht die exekutive in drei wochen wird
sich die exekutive wieder im kanzleramt
treffen
auf der suche nach einem weg den alle
mitgehen können
ja da gibt es fundamental
unterschiedliche ansichten über das
beherbergungs verbot theo koll in berlin
vor allem bayern hält vorläufig nun doch
an seinem fest was soll man nun davon
halten
und ich glaube man kann dieses in kauf
nehmen dass juristischen risiko sicher
auch werten als ausdruck der bayerischen
besorgnis über den anstieg der
infektionszahlen und da sind markus
söder und die kanzlerin ja schon länger
auf einer linie aber so wie es sein kann
dass die gerichte weitere beherbergungs
verbote kippen so deutlich wurde auch
die relativ begrenzte politische
durchsetzungsfähigkeit der kanzlerin in
den pandemie entscheidungen in corona
fragen ist angela merkel erkennbar eine
kanzlerin ohne die kleider der macht das
kanzleramt hatte schon im vorfeld
versucht das krisenbewusstsein der
anreisenden länder chefs und chefinnen
zu schärfen indem man von der
historischen dimensionen dieses treffens
sprach und auch der gestern vortragende
experte sollte mit seiner dramatischen
warnung genau das leisten aber die
mahnungen haben erkennbar wenig bewirkt
das eingeständnis des scheiterns wurde
heute morgen sehr deutlich als der
kanzleramtschef sich hinstellt und
meinte die menschen müssten vorsichtiger
sein als von der politik
und damit meinte er die
ministerpräsidenten vorgegeben die
kanzlerin wird offensichtlich weniger
ernst genommen als sie selbst die lage
sieht mit der folge dass jetzt aus sicht
der besorgten wertvolle zeit verstreicht
bis man sich dann erneut trifft und
treffen muss vielen dank theo in ordnung
von theo koll in berlin
soweit zum politischen ringen um den
richtigen weg in dieser virus krise
jetzt schauen wir
die aktuellen fallzahlen in deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet heute
6638 neue infektion an einem tag so
viele wie noch nie
allerdings sind diese werte nur bedingt
vergleichbar mit denen aus dem frühjahr
weil jetzt viel mehr getestet wird
künftig auch mit massen schnelltests die
in 15 bis 30 minuten klarheit schaffen
sollen vor allem in krankenhäusern oder
alten- und pflegeheim elisabeth schmidt
sechs wochen lang hatte dieses wohn und
pflegeheimen braunschweig das corona
virus im haus 5 der rund 170
bewohnerinnen und bewohner starben im
frühjahr die schnelltests sollen eine
weitere welle im heim möglichst
verhindern wir haben wirklich sehnlichst
darauf gewartet und wir haben zeit april
massiv eingefordert der mehraufwand
liegt beim personal wenn wir dann das
fachpersonal entsprechend schulen nur
geschultes personal darf bei den antigen
schnelltests rachenabstriche machen
die proben müssen nicht in ein labor
geschickt werden sondern das ergebnis
gibt es direkt vor ort damit positive
fälle erkannt werden ist beim
schnellverfahren allerdings eine höhere
virusmengen nötig als bei jenny wie
corona tests insgesamt ist dieser ansatz
in der regel weniger genau
als die pcr test aber für dieses
herausfiltern von menschen die viren
ausscheiden
daher scheint mir das ein sehr
vielversprechender weg bewohner besucher
oder personal von heimen oder kliniken
die keine corona symptome aufweisen aber
ansteckend sind sollen also schneller
erkannt werden
für schulen oder reisende sind die anti
gen tests zur zeit aber noch keine
alternative
am anfang haben wir nicht für alle alles
sondern wir fangen an vor allem mit dem
gesundheitswesen pflegeeinrichtungen
krankenhäuser arztpraxen in bestimmten
situationen und dann wird man sehen über
die zeit ob sie dann auch in weiteren
lebensbereichen eine zusätzliche
sicherheit geben können 9 millionen
schnelltests sollen in deutschland
zunächst jeden monat zur verfügung
stehen die kosten werden aus
steuermitteln finanziert sich gar nicht
erst an stecken mit dem virus ist
natürlich das beste innenräumen ist
lüften ganz entscheidend sagen experten
um viren aus der raumluft zu entfernen
das umweltbundesamt gibt jetzt eine
empfehlung an
alle schulen heraus die kernaussage alle
20 minuten die fenster auf und auch in
den pausen stoßlüften ist ein glas es
ist kalt geworden im klassenzimmer an
diesem stuttgarter gymnasium die devise
hier in den letzten wochen
dauerlüften jeder trägt seine
winterjacke manchen sogar ihre decken
dabei ist schon natürlich kalt aber ich
meine wenn man sich richtig anzieht dann
geht es eigentlich doch wenn's draußen
nun noch kälter wird wird es so nicht
mehr gehen stoßlüften empfiehlt das
umweltbundesamt den schulen jetzt
konkret alle 20 minuten alle fenster
komplett auf für drei bis fünf minuten
außerdem in allen pausen die vielfache
kritik dass die räume dabei im winter
massiv auskühlen sei falsch solche
mobilen raum luftfiltern als alternative
zum lüften steht das umweltbundesamt
dagegen skeptisch gegenüber also
luftreiniger sind allenfalls ergänzend
aber nie als ersatz oder als alleiniges
mittel um wir noch zu transportieren wie
aber umgehen mit klassenzimmern in die
nicht genug frischluft von außen kommen
kann
die sind laut umweltbundesamt derzeit
nicht für den unterricht geeignet
doch welche räume das genau betrifft ist
aus sicht des lehrerverbands oft unklar
was wir vermissen ist eine
bestandsaufnahme der
kultusministerkonferenz oder der
landesregierungen wie denn die lüftungs
situation wirklich vor ort ist und so
ist der alltag für viele schulleiter im
moment ziemlich herausfordernd
alle fahren auf sicht wieder so schön
heißt und jeder versucht nach bestem
wissen und gewissen die besten
bedingungen für die kollegen und
schülerinnen schüler zu schaffen an den
schulen schaut man nun gespannt auf die
kultusministerkonferenz die sich morgen
mit der korona lage beschäftigt und noch
eine meldung die in diesen zeiten
wichtig ist ärzte und ärztinnen können
patienten mit erkältungssymptomen ab
montag wieder telefonisch krankschreiben
die regelung gilt zunächst bis ende des
jahres und soll verhindern dass sich zu
viele menschen im wartezimmer drängen
und sich gegenseitig anstecken
das thema corona wird uns noch den
ganzen winter beschäftigen was drohen
könnte und wie schlimmeres abgewendet
werden soll
darum
jetzt in einem zdf spezial gleich im
anschluss und in der zdf- heute- app
können sie auf einer aktuellen karte
sehen ob ihr landkreis die kritischen
grenzwerte überschreitet die befürchtete
zweite welle von all unseren
europäischen nachbarn trifft sie
frankreich mit seinen 67 millionen
einwohnern wohl am härtesten
schon ende august durchbrach unser
nachbarland die schwelle von 6000
neuinfektionen pro tag
seither geht die kurve steil nach oben
aktuell meldet frankreich täglich mehr
als 20.000 neuinfektionen
wir müssen die kontrolle wieder erlangen
sagt präsident makro und zieht die
notbremse ab samstag gelten in neun
großstädten strikte ausgangssperren
christel hass vorjahr hatte damit
gerechnet trotzdem ist der pariser
bistro chef jetzt tief erschüttert ab
samstag 21 uhr gilt eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre
für henry sie bedeutet dass 70 prozent
weniger einnahmen
wir probieren das 3 4 tage aus dann
machen wir wohl zu
das ist der langsame tod der restaurants
präsident makro hatte die neuen
beschränkungen gestern in einem fernseh
interview angekündigt von neun uhr
abends bis sechs uhr morgens müssen
geschäfte restaurants theater schließen
wer dann noch unterwegs ist braucht
einen triftigen grund und eine
schriftliche genehmigung revier wir
müssen die privaten kontakte reduzieren
denn das sind die gefährlichsten also ja
die ausgangssperre ist angemessen
auch zu hause sollten nur höchstens
sechs personen zusammenkommen sagt der
präsident eine empfehlung in frankreich
sind private räumlichkeiten für den
staat nämlich tabu
das land erlebt eine starke zweite
corona welle im großraum paris sind 46
prozent der intensivbetten bereits
belegt die meinungen über die neuen
beschränkungen sind geteilt
wenn sie den leuten verbieten abends
auszugehen treffen die sich nachmittags
das war doch unausweichlich die leute
müssen verantwortung übernehmen
nur gemeinsam könne die krise bewältigt
werden sagt der präsident und macht sich
dann vielleicht ein bisschen selber
musiker wir schaffen das wegen der
steigenden zahlen hat die
bundesregierung nun auch die
französische grenzregion grund ist und
damit ganz frankreich zum risikogebiet
erklärt und in den niederlanden die
provinz zeeland an der nordsee
der brh exit auch dieses thema gibt es
noch und es drängt mehr denn je darüber
sprachen jetzt die 27 staats und
regierungschefs der eu
und zwar persönlich in brüssel nicht per
video schalte dabei machte kanzlerin
merkel klar man wolle ein abkommen aber
nicht um jeden preis
die 27 eu länder unterstrichen london
müsse sich bewegen um doch noch ein
abkommen hinzubekommen die zeit drängt
bis mitte november soll eine einigung
her
auch beim thema fischfang wirtschaftlich
nicht ganz so relevant aber symbolisch
von großer bedeutung
gunnar krüger berichtet fischerei ist
nur ein punkt im streit um den dreck cit
für die niederländer dirk ist es der
wichtigste da wo ich habe angst dass die
briten ihre gewässer dicht machen dann
knubbeln sich alle bei uns das kann
nicht gut gehen
großbritanniens wirtschaftszone dürfen
die nachbarn aus der eu noch mit nutzen
hier machen sie 60 prozent ihres fangs
71 von seinem fang verkauft das
königreich in die eu die damit druck
macht und gernot auf keinen fall werden
wir unsere fischer opfern wir haben den
dreck cit nicht gewollt er will den
black cit will bewegung doch die
deadline des boris johnson lassen
europas staats und regierungschefs
verstreichen
am nachmittag nannte jeder nur rote
linien bei der fischerei sowieso vor
allem aber beim wettbewerb also bei
gleichen umwelt und sozialstandards und
bei der frage wie deren einhaltung
kontrolliert wird
noch sprechen sie zum drexhage abwarten
ob es bei diesem gipfel bewegung gibt
yahoo de linien auf allen seiten statt
annäherung im rechtsstreit anne gellinek
in brüssel wird dann auch hoch gepokert
kurz vor toresschluss auf jeden fall ist
bei diesen verhandlungen jede menge
theaterdonner und taktik im spiel um
bronze hatte ja gesagt er werde erst
nach dem gipfel entscheiden ob die
verhandlungen überhaupt weitergehen
dabei hatte in der letzten woche in
verschiedenen hauptstädten schon
deponiert dass er sehr wohl an weiteren
gesprächen und auch an einem abkommen
interessiert ist und auch die staats und
regierungschefs hier hinter mir machen
es noch mal spannend sie tagen in
vertraulicher runde alle haben ihre
handys angeschlossen damit nichts nach
außen dringen kann und diskutieren die
frage inwieweit die eu den briten jetzt
doch noch ein stück entgegenkommen kann
zwei dicke brocken sind ungelöst die
frage wie viel fisch dürfen die europäer
künftig aus britischen gewässern holen
und die frage wie die eu verhindern kann
das britische unternehmen künftig
möglicherweise besser gestellt sein
könnten als europäische weil sie zum
beispiel umweltstandards unterlaufen
können diese fragen sollen jetzt in den
nächsten wochen noch geklärt werden
die eu ist bereit zu verhandlungen und
für einen deal und ist sogar bereit
dafür notfalls bis weit in den november
zu verhandeln
volles programm vielen dank anne
gellinek in brüssel
seit drei monaten spitzt sich die lage
in thailand zu immer wieder gibt es
massenproteste gegen die
militärregierung demonstrantinnen
fordern ihren rücktritt
und eine debatte über die rolle der
monarchie im land als antwort darauf hat
die regierung jetzt den verschärften
ausnahmezustand ausgerufen
mehr als vier menschen dürfen demnach
nicht mehr zusammenkommen
trotzdem gingen auch heute wieder
tausende auf die straße ja und damit
sind wir beim sport und beim tennis in
arbeit und da hat alexander zverev
gleich beim ersten spiel in köln gewann
ja nach seinem krankheitsbedingten
achtelfinal aus bei den french open vor
elf tagen heute ein souveräner auftritt
von deutschlands bestem tennisspieler
klarer zweisatzsieg und einzug ins
viertelfinale
fernando verdasco 36 jahre aktuelle
nummer 35 der welt ist nur im ersten
satz nahezu ebenbürtig den gewinn zverev
mit 6 zu viert im zweiten zieht er mit
zwei break deutlich davon
bei seinem ersten auftritt in
deutschland nach mehr als einem jahr
präsentiert sich zverev körperlich fit
und konzentriert präzise sein aufschlag
kraftvoll sein spiel der erste matchball
zum 6 2 1 satz gewinnen damaskus
widerstand bereits gebrochen weil im
auswärts gegner im viertelfinale
der unbekannte qualifikant laut harris
aus südafrika zum fussball bayern
münchen steigt erst heute abend in den
dfb-pokal 1 das spiel gegen den
fünftligisten fc düren war wegen
terminproblemen verschoben worden
die bayern natürlich klarer favorit
selbst wenn sie mit einer b mannschaft
antreten
für die amateure des fünftligisten ist
es das spiel ihres lebens kroner wenig
dürfen sie nicht in düren spielen dafür
aber in der großen allianz arena
das ist noch größer als ich dachte sagt
ist ein riesenunterschied
das ist natürlich auch das ist im
service liegt bei 1 und ja wir halt zu
dürren in bayern tor wird alexander
nübel sein debüt feiern und auch die
neuzugänge wie douglas costa sollen zum
einsatz kommen grund schonung der
stammkräfte nationalspieler werde nicht
spielen
die gespielt haben und deswegen haben
aber trotzdem noch im kader um einfach
auch die nächste runde wollen die
nächste runde einzuziehen
ein erinnerungsfoto aus münchen diese
dienstreise hat sich für den ersten fc
düren schon jetzt gelohnt
dabei sein ist auf jeden fall vielleicht
gibt es ja auch ein fußball wunder kann
sein hat zugegeben paar mal regen im
süden etwas sonne im norden bis zum
wochenende weiter geht erfahren sie
gleich von katja honnefer so viel von
uns für den moment mehr gibt es gleich
in unserem spezial zum starken anstieg
bei den corona zahlen und gegen 22 uhr
im heute journal mit marietta slomka
wir sagen danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
und wünschen nach einem recht angenehmen
abend bis morgen wieder um 19 uhr
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren viele
wolken liegen über mitteleuropa und auch
über südeuropa und da geht es zum teil
kräftige gewitter die richtung norden
für uns noch interessanter ist
vielleicht diese steve ihr westlich von
island denn das könnte anfang der woche
etwas mildere temperaturen heranbringen
heute war es ja meist bedeckt und es
fiel auch noch ein bisschen regen zum
teil nieselregen und einzig an der
nordsee da zeigte sich auch mal kurz die
sonne
den meisten regen gab es jetzt am tag
noch am alpenrand und das bleibt auch in
der nacht so sonst ist es häufig trüb
und im nordwesten auch mal klar dort
sinken die temperaturen bis 2 grad
dort ruht also bodenfrost sonst gehen
die temperaturen auf 9 bis 4 grad zurück
und steigen morgen über tag auf 6 grad
am alpenrand und bis zwölf grad zum
beispiel der lüneburger heide und auf
den ostfriesischen inseln
das wetter ist meist trüb und es gibt
auch noch ein bisschen regen am meisten
immer noch am alpenrand richtung
nordwesten wird es immer freundlicher
und der nordsee kommt die sonne raus bei
nordwind in den nächsten tagen geht es
doch relativ herbstlich trüb weiter am
montag steigen die werte dann auf neun
bis 15 grad schönen abend noch